now in the last Parliament the lib dems
had 56 MP some of the party expected to
lose around half of those something like
that but they never expected to lose as
many as they did down to single figures
the party now has just ate MPs so will
they ever return to being a major party
in British politics I'm joined now by
the president of the party Baroness
print and Sal Brinson and a very good
morning to you in and do you see a way
back from this well I do actually that
we've had a tradition of fighting back
from pretty difficult positions and we
already have the evidence for it in the
last 48 hours since the polls closed
over 5,000 people have joined the party
and the numbers are going up as we speak
and that means our total membership is
now up to 50,000 and rising so not even
you know just members of the public are
saying we want a liberal voice in
Britain and they're doing it in very
motivated way coming straight onto the
website and joining and I've been
talking to our candidates and some of
our party chairs around the country they
are absolutely up and ready to go it's
been a very difficult night but one
thing we are all clear about is that
Britain needs a liberal voice and we the
Liberal Democrats are there to provide
that it's pity they didn't join before
the general election isn't it something
but you know where will this revived
Liberal Democrat Party stand in the
political spectrum from your point of
view because if Labour when they recover
from their defeats go in a more Blairite
direction let me put it that way back
into the the middle ground Mr Cameron
governors are one nation conservative
what room is there for the Liberal
Democrat argument well actually there is
very distinctly of a role for a party
that is in favour of equality and
fairness and justice and rather than
looking at a left-right spectrum Liberal
Democrats have always preferred to look
at a liberal versus authoritarian
structure and the things that we stopped
the Conservatives doing in the last five
years we're beginning to see already
Theresa May as
about reintroducing the snoopers charter
which will affect everybody's rights to
keep their private conversations and
emails secret from the state they're
also threatening to get rid of the Human
Rights Act that's absolutely fundamental
British Liberty is about your rights as
an individual and they want to curtail
those we will of course be championing
the opposition to those what about
leadership you need a symbol let's the
head of the party and you've got seven
middle-aged white men to choose from yes
I'm the voters I'm afraid gave us that
choice after the other night but we have
seven people who have a great deal to
offer distinctive messages and we're
going to open the campaign for
nominations next week the result will be
in mid-july and it will be very
interesting to see which of the seven
put themselves forward for the campaign
I mean it does your party really have I
mean it's always an issue of the mental
energy to do it all again to claw your
way all the way back up that that snakes
and ladders of politics board and you
you're right back to zero we're not back
to zero and we're certainly down to a
low number but the one thing that we've
seen over the last two days has been the
party saying actually we're not just
down and out we are ready to start
fighting again now and I've already
heard of groups that are going to go out
and start door knocking and talking to
people in their areas we know we have
some major elections to fight next year
the Scottish Parliament the Welsh
Assembly the London Assembly as well as
a very large number of council seats we
don't have to wait we're out there
campaigning now but you have to
understand where your vote went don't
you and you and is the Liberal Democrat
task is almost more complicated than any
other parties because just looking at it
I've been looking at some of the
statistics of course you lost a lot of
votes to the Conservatives your form a
coalition partners but you lost votes to
you kit lib dems went to went to vote
for you Kip you lost votes to the Greens
perhaps more understandable that but
have you reformed the party how do you
appeal to all those groups well I think
the people who aren't well I can't say
for certain but the pea
who went to the greens and some who went
to UK were probably what would be
described as our traditional protest
vote I think the disappointing thing was
the conservative message over the last
few days about only 23 to a majority
combined with if you don't vote
conservative the SNP will be running the
country with labour and that was really
resonating on the doorstep so I agree
with Andrew Ron's Lee's comment that he
made to you earlier on your program that
actually people made up their minds in
the last few minutes in the polling
booth because although we knew it was
very tight it was the scale that
astonished us on the day a lot of people
said not lib dem supporters necessarily
said their hearts went out to what to Mr
Clegg went through course he won his
seat is there part of you is that part
of Mr Clegg that thinks thank you very
much conservatives look what we did for
the good of the nation we went into
coalition we formed a stable government
people said it wouldn't last five years
it didn't a lot was achieved on our
watch and and this is how you thank us
you campaign so hard against us you took
so many of our seats I'm not the only
liberal Democrat who has had messages
from senior conservatives not quite
apologizing but being really shocked by
the result they certainly didn't expect
the scale of it and actually I think
that's been one of the problems that
actually the unintended consequences of
the loss of so many liberal Democrat MPs
has for the moment changed the landscape
but the public aren't prepared to let
that go and that's why the astonishing
news of so many people joining the party
and continuing to join by the minute is
reassuring and actually will help us to
go out and fight again and come back
there are plenty of seats we're in a
strong second position I think that our
traditional voters will not be happy
with the very large cuts that the
Conservatives are about to introduce let
alone the Conservatives spit attitude on
Europe and the other things I've
mentioned already the Human Rights Act
and other freedoms and liberties that we
don't just assume in this country we
hold very dear as part of our principles
of being British sovereign it's been
great talking to you thank you very much
indeed banners Britain there the
presidents of the Liberal Democrats